[Applaudissements]
morgane ribout les diabolos l'est de
bombay devant mener leurs ventes ou
alors déjà et bravo jallet enfants
première chose très vite on y tient sur
igor s'en faut je veux maintenant mais
j'ai pas tellement qu'on fait là les
gars qu'est ce que 0 n'aura moi j'avais
dit à ma belle-fille que quand deux
personnes c'est mais très très fort
pulsé de bisous plus il y avait un
fluide d'amour qui rentrait dans le
ventre et qui donnait un bébé c'est pour
ralentir et bella cru mais parce qu'elle
avait 4 ans excuses n'auront pas vous tu
vas pas dire les un gros zizi qui rendra
à milou n'êtes pas soir
excuse moi c'est comme ça qu'on fait
alors
[Musique]
vous avez dit quoi vous parlez de m non
je dis ça on a mis 1 m dans la maman de
cyril féraud alors c'est quoi voilà ce
qu'on va prendre des choses alors la
sema show ça c'est une mallette ça c'est
une manette c'est soit c'est de l'eau
sage il fait toujours beau alors cette
manette votre chien quoi dans cette
malle et cette manette vous déjà trois
cent mille euros elle toute seule
non frérot fermé tout berne et thoune à
300000 euros de latour lafite rothschild
voilà tu imagines manu morais suz mais
quel est le gars qui va aller braquer
les bogdanoff
vous êtes un bras câble luc jacobs a
notamment fait un carnage
ils font très mal
le gardien mais le gars il faut vous y
allez braquer à 1000 mètres il pas
m'envoyer un coup de championnat à mme
simpara le gala qu'est ce qu'on fait là
alors faites par axa
c'est une machine on peut voir s'il ya
des fantômes ou pas mais c'est tout le
charme ne pas te mettre dans le cul ça
[Applaudissements]
faisait là l'opéra après l'émission
bateau mais pas vu de gucci en robe
longue de récital mais vous n'êtes pas
de boulot j'aurai fait mon âme et nora
c'est la seule me fais plus grand risque
de boue et les chocs roucourt mais je
ponds là mais regardez là je suis assise
ouais là je suis debout
[Applaudissements]
mais autant j'ai des talons je suivais
tout de même quelques heures le climat
gilles sunu à le faire et ça me parle
orientale ont alors allez-y là je suis à
vous ce salon salon
[Applaudissements]
de plus 40 non non il l'a donc lui n'a
pas tremblé
essayez berne et saihi verdez ouais
alors que moi vous tenez pas moi en fait
j'ai alors qu'ils respirent fonds de
quelque chose on économise sur la
traverse est pas une balle dans le but
de réduire leur activité qui tennis que
je vous jure qu'il se passe un truc de
ouf leur machine à machine garder je
vous jure c'est vrai il est en négatif
mais oui vous avez pu le gagner par hier
quelque chose on peut arriver à quelque
chose en vous il ya du césium 137
ah oui il ya du radium est alors encore
puis il ya des seniors elle est entrée
de la chine
mais oui mais oui j'aimerais mais bien
c'est ce que c'est vrai les trois
éléments mais avec votre machine vous
trouvez c'est bien joué sur gillet
rapidement des charlots ils ont des
têtes de charlot mais oui j'ai des trois
éléments au mois mais comment grâce à
patrick manceau j'ai pris de la terre
radioactifs
ah oui c'est vrai j'ai dû être
décontaminés en angleterre pour qu'on
voit si j'étais y avait un mec qui était
là et c'est il disait que c'était son
terrain et lui il est arrivé il a pris
la fessée matin